this is barbaric and we condemn it
without any reservations
we are at the grave moment for the
security of europe russia is attempting
to turn back the clock by force
to re-establish a sphere of influence
and to undermine the global rules that
have kept europe safe for decades
we have all made tireless efforts to
engage russia in diplomacy but moscow
has refused dialogue and chosen
aggression
nato and the eu stands with the brave
people of ukraine
we support ukraine's sovereignty and
territorial integrity and we support the
right of self-defense
there must be no misunderstanding or
miscalculation by russia
nato will do whatever it takes to
protect and defend all allies
in response to russia's massive military
buildup of the last months we have
already strengthened our collected
events
with more troops jets and ships from the
united states and many other allies
and our collective defense commitment
article 5 is ironclad
the world can see that unity is our
strength
early this morning president putin
ordered atrocious acts
of aggression
against a sovereign and independent
country and innocent people
we will hold russia accountable for this
outrageous violation of ukraine's
sovereignty and the territorial
integrity
what is at stake is not just on bus it's
not just ukraine what is at stake is the
stability of europe and the whole
international order our peace order
president putin chose to bring war back
to europe
in a determined and united response the
european union will make it as difficult
as possible for the kremlin to pursue
its aggressive actions
around about 30 minutes ago i had a
phone call with president zelinski he
asked us for whatever the different
stakeholders can do for help
we will later today present a package of
massive and targeted sanctions to
european leaders for their approval
we are coordinated closely with our
partners and allies the united states
the united kingdom canada and norway but
also for example japan and australia
this package will include financial
sanctions that harshly
limit russia's access to the capital
markets
these sanctions will have a heavy impact
russia's economy has already faced
intensive pressure in the recent weeks
and these pressures will now accumulate
these sanctions will suppress russia's
economic growth
increase the borrowing costs raise
inflation intensify capital outflow and
gradually erode its industrial basis
the second main pillar of our sanctions
concerns limiting russia's access to
crucial technology
we want to cut off russia industry
from the technologies desperately needed
today to build a future
our measures will weaken russia's
technology technological position in key
areas actually from which the elite
makes most of their money
and this ranges from high-tech
components to cutting-edge software this
will also seriously degrade the russian
economy in all areas in the future
let me be very clear
it is president putin
who will have to explain this to his
citizens
i know
that the russian people do not want this
war
the european union and nato have worked
in close complementarity
and this crisis will bring us even
closer together
it is our shared duty to stand up to the
gravest act of aggression on european
soil since decades
our unity is our best
strength the kremlin understands this
very well and that's why they have tried
their best to divide us but they have
achieved the exact opposite
we are more united
and more determined than ever
we are one union one alliance united in
purpose
we have with all the frontline member
states now explicit
contingency plans
to welcome and host immediately those
refugees
from ukraine
and what internally displaced people are
concerned we have a lot of support
through echo humanitarian aid shelter
and all the necessities people who are
internally displaced immediately need on
top there will be financial support
increased for ukraine on top of the 1.2
billion macro financial assistance which
is available available right now so the
preparedness
is fully alerted and
we hope that there will be as little as
possible refugees but we are fully
prepared for them and they are welcome